- And you'd have a very hard
time finding anyone cooler
than the two people we
have on the line right now.
I can't believe they're in
my show. I'm very excited.
We are obsessed with them.
Everyone is,
and one of them even wrote
the song I just sang,
which is why I was actually
even more terrified
to be singing Jolene (chuckles).
(audience laughing)
She sold over a hundred million albums.
He sold over 300 million books.
So together they have a new
novel called "Run Roses Run."
It's out now,
but more importantly they're good people
and support good courses like literacy,
health and community.
Let's say hello to miss the Dolly Parton
and James Paterson.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Hey!
- Oh my gosh it's so
great to see both of you.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to do my show.
- Well we love your show and we love you.
Thank you for having me.
- Oh! thank you.
Well, I have to say again,
it was great to sing your music last week
at the Academy of Country Music Awards,
but I will say it's always, always,
always going to be
terrifying to sing your song
in front of you while you're there.
Just so you know, I'm
always sweating profusely.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Oh well I mean, I don't
think you have to worry
with a voice like yours.
I was so honored and
nobody can sing like you.
(audience clapping and cheering)
So I was very proud of you and so proud
of your rendition of it.
It's great.
One of the best ever, ever, ever.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Oh, you are so kind.
And it was also,
we haven't really been
able to talk about it,
but it was cool to sing 9 to 5.
We did the kind of reimagined version
of 9 to 5 for your documentary
Still Working 9 to 5 which is amazing.
Not just the song but the
documentary is amazing.
So thank you for letting
me be a part of that.
I got to brag to Blake Shelton
about that moment.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Well you did a great job on that too.
I love how you took that
and just made it your own.
And I got a chance to sing
background for a change.
But I'm really proud of
that rendition of it.
And I think hopefully
it'll do well for us.
It's great in the documentary.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God.
It's a really cool thing.
James do you have a favorite Dolly song?
- Yeah well, first of
all also the new album,
Run Rose Run,
I love Big Dreams and Faded Jeans
and Woman Up (And Take
It Like A Man), right.
- I love that one.
- Right Dolly?
- I love (chuckles)
- Yeah, he's always
loved that one (chuckles)
- And there's My Life
Would Suck Without You.
I love that one.
- Yes!
- Oh, wait a minute, it's yours Kelly.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Yes, James Patterson
knows my music (chuckles)
Oh my God, that's amazing.
Did y'all know each other?
How did you end up working
together on this book?
- Dolly.
- You won't tell it? Well-
- I came down to Nashville.
I went banging,
I came down to Nashville.
I went to college in
Nashville at Vanderbilt.
So I loved that town anyway.
And I used to go to the Grand
Ole Opry when it was in town.
And I just went banging
on her door and I said,
you wanna write a book?
(Kelly chuckles)
She said, who are you?
- And,
(all laughing)
- Hardly, actually, I was very honored
that he would ask me to write a book.
When he first asked if I'd
like to write a book with him.
And I thought, well,
what do you need me for?
You only sold 400 million books so far.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And he said, well, I have an idea.
Would you like to hear it?
And I said, yeah.
So he did come to Nashville.
We talked it over and the rest
is gonna be history, I hope.
- I love that.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Can you, is it kind of
about the Nashville dream?
Like, what is the book about?
- Well, it is about the Nashville dream
and you know, both of us
Dolly and I, Dolly came
from the Hills of Tennessee and I came
from this little town up in
New York state, way, way up.
And both of us, probably a
million to one chance, you know,
odds against us making it.
And the same thing in
this book, Run Rose Run.
The singer, AnnieLee keys, you know,
she's got a lot of talent
and she comes to Nashville,
but you know, well, you know, Kelly,
I mean, it's hard to make it.
- Yeah.
- With all the talent in the world.
And that's what the story's about.
She has, her background
is kind of weird, Dolly.
- Yeah, and my background
is kind of weird.
(James chuckles)
No actually, it's about a young girl
that's trying, like she's running
from something and running to something.
You have to read the book to know all,
get to know all of the things about it.
But it's about her journey.
And then there's an older character
that was once a big star,
Ruthanna writer that
she still writes songs,
she has her own studio, has her own band,
but she considers herself retired.
And so Ruthanna kind of
becomes a mentor, you know,
to AnnieLee and they become friends.
And it's a wonderful
story about bad management
and about all the things that can happen
to you in the business.
In addition to AnnieLee
running from this mystery thing
that is part of the whole book.
- Yeah.
- And it's really a clever little book.
And I was so honored to
get to write some with him.
I was a little intimidated
'cause I've never written a novel.
- And I relate to Ethan in the book.
- And you were what James?
- I relate to Ethan in the book.
He's a handsome, young, up and
coming singer and, you know,
but she says, I can't relate to him.
I gotta relate to the older guys.
So, all right I'll relate anyway.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- No, wait-
- Yeah, there's Ruthanna's,
anyway, Ruthanna, she has a manager
that she loves called
Jack the older woman.
So he's gonna be, he's
saying he can play that
'cause we are gonna be
doing a movie at some point.
- I know I heard about that.
(audience clap and cheer)
I heard that you were gonna make it
into a movie and I think
that's such a brilliant idea.
I wonder though, Dolly,
any pieces of your life,
I mean, since James asked you to do this,
any pieces of your kind of seep
into this character or any of
the characters in the book?
- Oh, of course.
I related to every single
one of them, the young girl
and even Ethan that
James was talking about.
'Cause I related to all
the young men that I met
when they were coming to
Nashville, all the people,
even like, you know, Merle
Haggard, who I loved and he was,
we were getting to make it
pretty much at the same time.
And then I sang a duet
called Demons from the book,
one of the songs I wrote
from the album with
Merle Haggard's son, Ben.
So I'm really excited about that.
So there's a lot of things I relate to.
Of course, James has this wonderful mind
for creating everything,
but it is something at
least I can relate to,
and love the story.
- Yeah. And Kelly, one
of the really cool things
that what makes this so
different is that Dolly,
you know, did an album.
- Yeah, I was about to say that, yeah.
- The songs that you read about
in the book and it's amazing.
And the album is spectacular.
It's a wonderful, wonderful
album with 12 new songs and-
- Well, she's Dolly Parton.
- There's the album, Run Rose Run.
(Kelly chuckles)
- But that's her journey.
(audience clapping) You should
be able to read the book
and then you listen to
the songs or vice versa,
start with the songs
and then read the book.
It's a very, and I don't think
any anybody's ever done it.
- I was gonna say, it's
a very clever thing too
because you're not only
into the novel, but you're
into the music, which creates
a bigger story in your head.
You know, I always say our
mind doesn't have a budget
so the best movies are like
in your head almost, you know.
So you're like creating this
and you've given us a compilation album,
like for the album too,
it's a companion to the book.
So I'm excited about the movie.
I'm excited about all of it.
It's so cool.
I love like two people that we all love,
working together to create
something that's so magical.
(audience clapping)
So thank you for doing that.
Everybody, James and Dolly's book
and Dolly's new album are
both called Run Rose Run
and they air out.
Now you gotta check it out.
Thank y'all so much for calling
and I appreciate you taking your time.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- All right.
- Thank you, love you.